[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts de la
semaine à l'assemblée et au sénat avec
orianne mancini bonjour henry a
gentiment est notre invité cette semaine
et eric coquerel député la france
insoumise de seine-saint-denis bonjour à
vous merci d'être avec nous et cette
semaine a pris fin le long feuilleton du
remaniement et l'exécutif est allé
piocher au parlement deux présidents
groupe à l'assemblée nationale et un
sénateur font leur entrée au
gouvernement
et pour ses premières questions
d'actualité comme ministre de
l'intérieur
christophe castaner a été fortement
chahuté sénat début du long marathon
budgétaire cette semaine l'assemblée
nationale a entamé l'examen du projet de
loi de finances pour 2010 9 présenté par
le gouvernement comme celui du pouvoir
d'achat ce que conteste l'opposition
dans le même temps le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale est
examiné en commission à l'assemblée
et puis le sénat a bouclé l'examen de la
réforme de la justice après deux
semaines de débat le vote solennel aura
lieu mardi
le texte a été considérablement remanié
par les sénateurs et on commence cette
semaine par le remaniement est d'abord
le baptême du feu mouvementée de
christophe castaner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une équipe cohérente pour les uns un
remaniement pour rien pour les autres
mardi l'exécutif a finalement abattu son
jeu après deux semaines d'attentes la
nouvelle équipe gouvernementale s'est
affiché aux questions au gouvernement à
l'assemblée et au sénat c'est là que le
principal promu du gouvernement
christophe castaner nommé ministre de
l'intérieur a suscité l'ire des
sénateurs dès sa première prise de
parole retour sur ce baptême du feu
mouvementée avec à stéphane à magnan
séance des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement mardi le sénateur philippe
dallier interpelle avec beaucoup
d'émotion le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur sur le décès d'un adolescent
dans son département la seine saint
denis en réponse très politique de
christophe castanet c'est pour cela
monsieur le sénateur qu'après la
suppression de 12 mille policiers et
gendarmes en france après le
démantèlement de nos services
d'information nous nous sommes engagés
le gouvernement de la mandature
précédente et ce gouvernement actuel a
recruté dix mille policiers
supplémentaires je suis sidéré par votre
réponse sidéré par ce que vous n'avez
pas compris le sens de ma question et je
crains que vous n'ayez pas compris ce
qui se passe dans ces territoires
bientôt perdus de la république puis la
tension monte d'un cran lorsque
christophe castaner répond un autre
sénateur du département sur le même
sujet merci monsieur le sénateur roger
d'avoir posez votre question avec la
sagesse nécessaire à ce problème qui
préoccupe chacun parce que
parce qu en faire un sujet de petite
politique politicienne ne me semble pas
la meilleure façon d'agir
excédés les sénateurs les républicains
quitte l'émission de christophe castaner
qui est le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur a répondu d'une façon
absolument désinvolte en mettait en
cause la question que posait pourtant
très sont très sereins pédalier à sa
sortie christophe castaner et huées dans
la salle des conférences du sénat
mais pour le groupe la république en
marche la responsabilité revient aux
sénateurs les républicains la façon de
poser les questions sans doute avec
talent en ligue 1 tout avec talent mais
néanmoins sur un ton très politicien et
avec une forme de cynisme amener une
réponse qui était juste christophe
castaner avait déjà connu des tensions
avec le sénat pendant la sphère benalla
il avait accusé les sénateurs de vouloir
destituer le président de la république
à cette occasion eric coquerel
christophe castaner at il confondu son
ancien rôle de porte flingue du
gouvernement avec son nouveau rôle
premier flic de france
en théorie il aurait dit c'était le
porte-parle gouvernement vis-à-vis de
l'assemblée le porte-flingue hui il va
peut-être pas le nom ans et on se dit
que c'est un triste sire à l'intérieur
quoi voilà ce que je retiens parce que
là c'est quand même incroyable
je connais philippe dallier on a on
n'est pas d'accord sur beaucoup de
choses mais on a été ensemble voir le
premier ministre avec tous les
parlementaires de toutes les couleurs
politiques de seine saint denis pour
poser le problème de l'inégalité
de fait on y pense en seine-saint-denis
le fait que l'état ne les tac le fait
que deux sur tous les plans en termes
d'éducation en termes de sécurité en
termes d'emploi c'est un département qui
jaillit dire la république ne ne fait
pas son devoir
les citoyens ne sont pas égaux par
rapport à d'autres alors il ya d'autres
endroits où c'est le cas mais la cen sad
vraiment salik hull et l'art et la
question elle était dans ce sens là
après un drame terrible qui nous a tous
beaucoup touché tout le ce a touché tous
les français vont partir dans ces
briques en seine-saint-denis bon il y en
a eu plusieurs comme ça moi aujourd'hui
sur ma circonscription heureusement pas
aussi aussi qui n'est pas terminée pas
par par une ou un décès donc j'ai vu sa
question et castagne répond de manière
totalement politicienne quoi totalement
politiciennes alors je vais vous dire je
me demande s'il n'est pas en train
d'essayer de faire un concours pour être
pire que
à l'intérieur voilà déjà en affaires
benalla on se rappelle on cherchait à
l'assemblée parce qu'on cherche avoir
des réponses du gouvernement il était à
la buvette à côté pendant des heures au
lieu de venir s'expliquer devant
l'assemblée de répondre aux
parlementaires c'est les gens qui sont
dépositaires la souveraineté du peuple
vraiment la cheville j'ai découvert ça
absolument abasourdi et je comprends
qu'il était hué franchement que l'on
rappelle que christophe castaner avant
de laminer internet et secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
sera comment vous expliquer qu'avec ce
rôle il aurait dû connaître les
parlementaires il en arrive à provoquer
ce genre de situation sénart qui est
rare au sénat
mach est passé peut-être c'est peut-être
un peu un état d'esprit de cette
nouvelle majorité qui franchement jeu
individuellement quand vous rencontrez
les gens
les discussions peuvent être sympa
experts mais quand ils sont en groupe
même ici on le voit à l'assemblée il ya
un côté il ya un côté vraiment méprisant
par rapport au reste des parlementaires
par rapport aux groupes d'opposition
moi je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose qui
qui qui qui sent pas bon dans le
maquereau nisme à ce niveau là c'est pas
parce qu'on y majoritaire qu'on doit
mépriser les oppositions qu'on doit les
caricaturer et malheureusement ccc
procéda si je pense les casters du point
de vue là bas voilà il est parfaitement
à l'image du maquereau nisme il faudrait
faire attention parce que je suis ce
genre de réactions dans l'opinion à mon
avis c'est très très mal perçu alors dit
à mon avis je me trompe pas ce qu'on
peut retenir aussi de ce remaniement
c'est que l'exécutif a largement pioché
dans les effectifs du parlement deux
présidents de groupe de l'assemblée font
leur entrée au gouvernement celui du
groupe modem marc fesneau nommé ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
et le président du groupe lune et y agir
franck riester nommé ministre de la
culture d un sénateur fait également son
entrée au gouvernement didier guillaume
sénateur rds de la drôme ancien
président du groupe socialiste nommé lui
ministre de l'agriculture et puis en
sortant du gouvernement reviendra au
sénat
jacques mézard dans un mois il
retrouvera son siège de sénateur du
cantal
eric coquerel le choix de marc fesneau
normalement ce poste de ministre
relations des relations avec le
parlement est plutôt donner à quelqu'un
la majorité du parti majoritaire lasser
c'est le modem est ce que c'est le signe
d'une volonté quand même de emmanuel
macron de dire je vais peut-être plus
écouter le parlement où je crois surtout
qui est bonne macro et
fragilisée que il faut absolument qu'ils
arrivent à consolider son seul aly modem
je rappelle que marc fesneau effet un
très gros résultat à l'assemblée
nationale pour le titre opéable le poste
de perchoirs c'est étonnant qu'elle doit
à plus de 80 voix ce qui est en plus ça
ils s'étaient présentés c'est pas
courant que quelqu'un de la majordome
un autre groupe de la majorité se
présente contre celui qui est proposé en
réalité par le groupe principal donc
voilà je pense que maintenant il va
permettre de réconcilier le gouvernement
avec les oppositions il sera plus à
l'écouté vous pensez écoutez c'est
quelqu'un d'affable ça c'est clair
quelqu'un de conciliant cas là aussi un
contact facile
je pense qu'il sera peut-être il sera
peut-être plus facile qu'avec eux avec
christophe castaner voilà bon après le à
temps et de fond c'est que la politique
va être la même écoeurant traces
gouvernement à la fois des gens qui
après en khl agrobusiness comme comme
didier guillaume desgens même qui rend
tout miss à l'écologie et qui sont
inquiétés il ya encore quelques jours
qui tenaient des postes importants à
danone ça me rassure pas sur la
politique sur la politique hui ça va
être la même chose
voilà donc les noms on va penser
important cette semaine toute la
politique se fait à l'elysée moi c'est
ça c'est ça dont je suis convaincu et le
problème la raison pour laquelle
remaniement à dure autant de temps c'est
que et mener le mac on contourne
absolument à la fois son premier nice le
gouvernement est au tout est centralisé
à l'elysée on poursuit cette semaine
avec l'assemblée nationale qui a entamé
le marathon budgétaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lundi les députés ont démarré l'examen
du projet de loi de finances pour 2010 9
avec le volet recettes plus de deux
mille amendements au menu le
gouvernement défend un pouvoir d'achat
un budget du pouvoir d'achat tourner
vers ceux qui travaillent les
oppositions crie au mensonge sur les
baisses d'impôts clément méric le
pétrole flambe et la taxe carbone
augmente à nouveau
il n'en fallait pas plus pour que
l'opposition défendent à l'unisson le
pouvoir d'achat des automobilistes
chez nous quand on travaille quand on
doit emmener les enfants à l'école quand
on doit aller chez le médecin on fait
régulièrement et ça n'a rien d'anormal
un plein par semaine ça veut dire 400
euros de perte de pouvoir d'achat sur
l'année une fois n'est pas coutume les
députés communistes votre un amendement
de la droite parce que en matière de
fiscalité punitive
on est là avec la sphère de l'essence
sur un gros sujet travers cet amendement
nous le soutiendrons c'est la défense
des ouvriers de ce pays c'est la défense
de celles et ceux qui se lèvent le matin
pour aller bosser de celles et ceux dont
vous fermer les usines mais ce sont les
pressions venues de la majorité qui
finissent par faire céder le
gouvernement la prime à la conversion
est étendue aux voitures hybrides
rechargeables et ceux qui renoncent à se
chauffer au fioul obtiennent un crédit
d'impôt les frondeurs rentrer dans le
rang effectivement moi je prends acte de
ces vraies avancées
donc ça c'est des premiers éléments qui
répondent à ce qu'on souhaitait quand la
droite accuse cette fiscalité écologique
de plomber la compétitivité des
entreprises
bruno le maire monte au créneau pour
aller parler de la misère des ours
blancs la banquise de la banquise qui
fond des territoires qui disparaissent
la pluie qui tombe trop du soleil qui
chauffent trop alors là on trouve tout
le monde mais quand il faut avoir le
courage d'assumer devant les français il
faut changer notre fiscalité pour
qu'elle devienne vert il n'ya plus que
cette majorité c'est finalement sur un
sujet moins attendu que la majorité fait
entendre sa voix à un coup de force mené
en douceur par aurélien tâcher de
l'amendement que je vous propose
étudier maintenant c'est la création
d'un crédit d'impôt pour les français
qui héberge des réfugiés à hauteur de
1500 euros par an et donc de 5 euros par
part nuit d' impossible de contrôler un
tel dispositif répond le rapporteur du
budget mais la majorité n'écoute ni le
rapporteur ni le gouvernement n'ont est
adopté de longues heures de débats
attendent encore les députés jusqu'au
vote solennel prévu mardi
la séance est levée et cochrane l'étude
se sont concentrés sur cette question de
la fiscalité écologique la france
insoumise est un fervent défenseur de la
nécessité d'une transition écologique
est ce que le gouvernement a raison de
tenir bon sur ce sujet oui d'ailleurs on
a voté l'amendement 19,1 parce que je
pense que s'il y avait eu recul hilippe
il est pas satisfaisant il ya plein de
d'entreprise qui peut lui énormément qui
ne paye pas au niveau 2 du monde de leur
niveau de pollution que vont elles sont
coupables mais n'empêche si on avait
reculé là dessus je pense que c'était la
voie ouverte en réalité à détricoter
toute possibilité de deux fiscalités
écologique donc on a décidé de le voter
même si par ailleurs on peut
effectivement aujourd'hui se plaint du
fait que c'est beaucoup les particuliers
qui sont taxés pour les questions
écologiques avec des taxis à certains
moments d'ailleurs grève le pouvoir
d'achat ça d'une part et très peu
malheureusement ce qui peut le plus par
en prendre à proposer un moment pour
taxer le kérosène pour l'aviation ça a
été refusé
c'est ce genre d'exemple dans le monde
une vraie taxation écologique devrait
rapporter plusieurs milliards
supplémentaires par après ce qui est le
cas aujourd'hui
alors vous avez présenté cette semaine à
l'assemblée un contre budget estampillé
la france insoumise si vous étiez au
pouvoir vous dégagiez 52 milliards
d'euros notamment en taxant le capital
et les réinjecter riait dans le secteur
public en particulier voulant seriez un
grand plan d'investissement pour
l'écologie 43 milliards d'euros avec ce
budget la dette atteindrait les 4% du
pib et le déficit le déficit atteindrait
les 4 % du pib la dette dépasserait
certainement les 100 milliards vous
assumer ce choix est alors pour être
plus exact en terme de fonctionnement ça
s'équilibre en fonctionnement aux
dépenses recettes pardon c'est le plan
d'investissement valadas et le plan
d'investissement qui creuse la dette et
on
le revendique pourquoi parce que pour
nous la tête principal c'est la dette
écologique
c'est la seule quelque part qui qui
portent véritablement atteinte à
l'intérêt général l'intérêt général
humain ne serait-ce que de pouvoir
continuer à vivre sur cette planète
donc on ne devrait pas un moment donné
mégoter sur l'investissement nécessaire
pour les générations à venir
vous savez il ya une bonne et une
mauvaise dette il ya la mauvaise dette
sait par exemple qu'en 2009 sarkozy mais
474 milliards pour sauver les banques
sans aucune contrainte aucune
nationalisation elles ont pu continuer
leur le même business par la suite la
même les mêmes spéculation etc
et puis la bonne dette celle qui
investit justement pour les générations
à venir qui construit des hôpitaux qui
construit des universités parce qu'on a
aussi une part d'investissement social
de ce qu'on propose
et surtout ça c'est vrai nous on met 30
milliards dès le départ pour le
développement d'énergies de durable pour
une vraie isolation thermique des
bâtiments
et en plus ça fait vivre le bel le btp
c'est à dire cdc des commandes de l'état
qui servent l'économie et on revendique
que la première année eh bien on dépasse
les critères de les critères de
maastricht est ce que j'aurai dire c'est
que économiquement tout ça ça se tient
c'est à dire que si on regarde son sac
en last année on a choisi de ne poser un
budget ben en gros qui a un budget dit
d'urgence si on arrivait au pouvoir qui
sait comment on arrive actifs y est les
choses mais sur cinq ans on estime que
la pointe du macro économiques avec
l'investissement la relance de
l'activité
écologiquement soutenable qu'on propose
pas la société on reviendrait à peu près
à 3% déficit
la première année 4% ça ferait pas de
mal à l'économie française par contre ça
sera l'affrontement panafricaine vox
elle ça serait un affrontement politique
ça vous l'assumez langues assurent la
formation
allez on en vient notre troisième thème
le budget de la sécurité sociale cette
fois examiné cette semaine en commission
à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et les débats ont été marqués par une
surprise cette semaine les députés ont
adopté mardi en commission un amendement
qui prévoit de moduler la hausse de la
csg pour les retraités en fonction de
leur niveau de revenu une disposition
votée contre l'avis du rapporteur
général et qui embarrasse le
gouvernement
certains veulent y voir le début d'une
fronde au sein du groupe la république
en marche le résumé des débats de la
semaine est signée l amende à gaza
l'opposition qui attaque le gouvernement
sur la hausse de la csg pour les
retraités
c'est une habitude mais cette fois ce
sont des députés de la majorité qui s'y
mènent augmenter la csg pour les
retraités pour relancer l'économie oui
mais pas de manière uniforme
il est temps effectivement d'écouter
tous les gens qui viennent dans nos
permanences il est temps d'écouter des
députés aussi pour la fois la même
enveloppe mais juste un peu plus de
justice sociale
une vingtaine de députés la république
en marche ont signé un amendement non
pas pour revenir sur cette hausse mais
pour instaurer un taux de csg progressif
une initiative qui a peu goûté le
responsable du texte pour le groupe
majoritaire le groupe en marche de tient
son programme les arguments ont été
excellemment abordé par mes collègues
tout à l'heure aussi nous rejetterons
ces amendements l'opposition se régale
de voir la majorité divisée
on assiste nous un débat interne la
majorité ample en marche pas très bien
on assiste dès simplement parce que
certains ont ouvert les yeux ouvert les
yeux depuis quelques semaines ou
quelques mois dans leur permanence parce
qu'ils ont vu arriver des personnes les
retraités qui ont commencé à râler
l'amendement est adopté contre l'avis du
rapporteur
le débat devrait s'intensifier pour la
séance publique
c'était un autre sujet potentiellement
explosif la fin des exonérations de
cotisations pour les travailleurs
saisonniers
le mécanisme est finalement maintenu
dans ce projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale également la
première étape de la mise en place du
reste à charge zéro c'est à dire
permettre demain à tous les français qui
doivent en bénéficier de pouvoir
s'équiper
en audio prothèse pour pouvoir bien
entendre en prothèse dentaire pouvoir
bien manger et boire sourire et en
optique pour pouvoir bien voir autre
disposition votée la fin des cotisations
salariales pour les heures
supplémentaires
le plfss a été adoptée en commission
mercredi soir il arrive dans l'hémicycle
de l'assemblée nationale mardi après
midi
alors eric coquerel faire payer
davantage les retraités ayant les plus
hauts revenus pour exonérer ceux qui ont
qui ont des retraites plus modèles sont
bien de voir cet amendement adopté cette
semaine en commission par les marcheurs
vous pourriez voter un tel amendement
dans les mots c'est peut-être mais ça
montre qu'ils sont gênés aux entournures
parce qu'en réalité les chiffres
économiques du début de l'année 2018 le
premier sommet sont très mauvais baisse
du pouvoir d'achat baisse de la
consommation populaire il ya les 1% de
français les plus riches comme le
prévoyait le projet de la finance qui
s'en sortent plus que bien ou alors
courbe monte en termes de pouvoir
d'achat donc je suppose que les
marcheurs sont un peu gênés aux
entournures
il essaye de trouver des arrangements
alors notamment avec le fait de rendre
progressif la csg parce que la csg savès
à remplacer une part des cotisations
sociales
c'est une fiscalisation de de la
protection sociale ce qui d'ailleurs
pour notre part nous questionne on n'est
pas bon on n'est pas vraiment forcément
pour 6m ici les ont mis en place au
moins qu'il soit progressif mais par
ailleurs quand ce que la majorité ce
ratio ils ont gardé sa globalité quand
même le presque la globalité de leurs
plfss 3,8 milliards de dépenses en moins
pour les hôpitaux pour la santé le fait
qu' on va désindexer désormais les
allocations familiales les pensions de
retraite
l'apl ce qui va coûter encore de
l'argent justement aux classes les plus
défavorisées
et puis enfin alors que j'entendais tout
à l'heure cette idée de 10,2 d'enlever
les allégations des les cotisations
sociales sur les sur les heures
supplémentaires c'est une vraie
catastrophe
une vraie catastrophe d'abord parce que
ça sera encore moins de cotisations donc
à la fin vous verrez qu on nous dira
qu'on peut moins payé la santé et tout
ça bon et puis c'est une vraie
catastrophe parce que c'est
une prime j'allais dire malheureusement
fait à la fois pour les entreprises pour
un travail que leur coûtera toujours
moins cher et puis pour le fait de ne
pas embaucher les personnes qui
pourraient correspondre à ce volume
d'heures nécessaires pour pour la
production
donc c'est plus de chômage mais juste
par un mot sur l'arrêté puisqu'ils ont
encore un manifesté cette semaine dans
ce plfss
il ya le gouvernement introduit une
correction de mesures fiscales qui
compense la hausse de la csg pour trois
cent mille retraités est ce que vous ne
reconnaissez pas qu'elle essaye de
frapper c'est quand même moins d'efforts
sur ces retraités sont corrige le tiers
aux mille au début des annonces et 308
maintenant c'est 100 milles alors on va
voir comment se termine d'amendements
qui a été votée parce que j'attends de
voir si à la fin du fin malheureusement
c'est un moment reste intacte mais non
non ça corrige pas le tir je veux dire
tu vois que vous pouvez regarder toutes
les statistiques de mises pour l'instant
les retraités sont parmi les grands
perdants en a d'autres mais parmi les
grands perdants
la preuve des quinze mois de damon
macron et encore une fois c'est une
politique à courte vue la politique
d'enrichir les plus riches en pensant
que ça va favoriser l'économie
ça ne marche pas alors la politique qui
consiste à enlever du pouvoir d'achat à
des millions de français et bien à la
fin ça contracte l'économie c'est ce
qu'est en train de se passer
on va terminer cette semaine avec le
sénat qui a bouclé l'examen de la
réforme de la justice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après deux semaines d'examen la première
lecture de la réforme de la justice et
donc achevé cette semaine au sénat avant
un vote solennel mardi et le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que les scènes les
sénateurs ont réécrit la loi fabien la
guerre le gouvernement je voulais
simplifier le système et désengorger les
tribunaux et les prisons projet fourre
tout répond la droite sénatoriale qui a
fait subir à nicole belloubet de
nombreux revers dans l'hémicycle comme
sur l'échelle des peines pour lutter
contre la surpopulation carcérale
d'exécutif voulait supprimer les peines
de moins d'un mois ferme et favoriser
les alternatives à la prison comme le
bracelet électronique pour les peines de
moins de six mois
cessons l'hypocrisie qui consiste à
prononcer des peines d'emprisonnement de
moins de un mois et à ne pas les
exécuter
reconnaissons que les peines de moins de
un mois ne servent à rien il faut
trouver d'autres peines rejet des
sénateurs pour eux c'est aux magistrats
de décidé d'aménager ou non les peines
courtes pour lesquels ils ont aussi
supprimé le recours automatique au juge
d'application des peines des peines
d'emprisonnement d'une durée inférieure
ou égale à un nom devrait par principe
est aménagé par la juridiction de
jugement
en prenant en compte la personnalité du
condamné et sa situation matérielle en
matière civile
l'exécutif voulait accélérer la
procédure de divorce en supprimant
l'audience de conciliation qu'il juge
inutiles
là aussi refus des sénateurs l'audience
de conciliation est utile elle est utile
parce que c'est souvent le premier
moment où ceux qui sont en conflit
peuvent se voir éventuellement discuter
je ne dis pas que la conciliation est
certaine à coup sûr petite victoire pour
la garde des sceaux en revanche le sénat
a accepté l'expérimentation pour trois
ans des tribunaux criminels
départementaux compétent en matière de
viol ils doivent permettre de
désengorger les cours d'assises
aujourd'hui des crimes comme le viol ne
sont pas jugés en tant que crime parce
que les victimes ont parfois besoin d'un
jugement plus rapide ou souhaitent un
jugement plus rapide et donc de ce fait
ces crimes sont correctionnalisés
monsieur le rapporteur viens de vous le
dire je ne suis pas favorable à quelque
chose qui s'oppose à la vérité
judiciaire
hier à contre-courant de la ligne
sécuritaire dlr la droite au sénat s'est
enfin posée en garante des libertés
par exemple en s'opposant à l'extension
de certains pouvoirs d'enquêté des
procureurs alors eric coquerel on vient
de le voir le texte du gouvernement
prévoyait d'étendre les pouvoirs du
procureur le sénat n'a pas suivi il
avait raison bien sûr qu'il eut raison
bien sûr on a on a comme un problème en
france avec cet aspect de la justice on
en parlera tout à l'heure je pense par
rapport aux perquisitions s'il est
compris dans un boîtier victimes
mais le procureur il est directement il
faut pas tourner autour du pot il est
directement reliée au ministère des sous
il n'ya pas longtemps mails mâcon a
revendiqué lé là le lien politique avec
les procureurs vous voyez bien que c'est
un aspect où la justice n'est plus tout
à fait indépendante et donner plus de
moyens à cette justice là ben
déséquilibrer la justice au profit de ce
pont levis et un véritable problème ça
avait été déjà fait avec la loi perben 2
qui permet justement les enquêtes
préliminaires comme sage amorce le
prince et le sujet pour le sujet suivant
et là la survie fait que l'aggraver donc
merci aux sénateurs d'avoir avoir
rectifié pas pour l'instant en tout cas
cet aspect de la loi on va y venir à 1,6
g suivant cette perquisition menée au
siège de votre mouvement qui a donné
lieu à des scènes houleuse à cette
semaine perquisitions menées dans le
cadre de deux enquêtes préliminaires
portant sur des emplois présumés fictifs
d'assistant parlement européen et sur
les comptes de campagne de la
présidentielle de 2017
des images qui ont fait réagir le
premier ministre lors des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement à
l'assemblée on écoute j'ai vu des images
dont je vais vous dire monsieur le
député qu'elles m'ont choqué
monsieur le député
les images que j'ai vues étaient d'une
très grande violence d'une très grande
violence à l'égard de fonctionnaires de
police d'une très grande violence à
l'égard de procédure qui ne relèvent pas
du gouvernement et qui relève et qui ne
relèvent pas du gouvernement et je ne
crois pas et je ne crois pas monsieur le
député que nous gagnons quoi que ce soit
à mettre en cause la dépendance de la
justice eric coquerel vous comprenez que
ces images de violence venant de
représentants de la république ait pu
choquer d'abord il n'y a pas eu de
violence vis-à-vis de policiers ou de
juge voilà je crois déjà président
chaude 6 lits à bulles en scylla non il
n'y a pas eu violence j'étais sur place
il ya pas eu violence un d'accord s'il
ya eu violence un monde et ça a été le
fait d'un des policiers notamment qui a
fait en sorte qu'il ya 4 personnes 4 de
mes camarades qui ont aujourd'hui des
certificats médicaux qui atteste de
violence reçu d'accord d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses ce policier a été réprimée a
réprimandé par son supérieur au moment
des faits donc il ya pas eu de violence
il ya eu de la colère ça c'est vrai de
l'énervement minutes ça c'est évident
mais il n'y a pas eu violence moi je
voudrais dire que la vraie violence la
vraie violence c'est que il y à un
déséquilibre total dans la façon dont
nous avons été traités sur ces affaires
total y compris on nous dit ah mais vous
êtes et justiciables et bien voilà nous
voulons aider justiciable comme les
autres nous voulons être traités comme
les autres partis toute la question
c'est que sur une affaire où on est sur
des comptes de campagne qui ont été
validés avec quelqu'un qui justement est
là et la personne qui quelque part à me
la faire sur le sujet qui était un des
rapporteurs delà de la commission de
contrôle qui ère s'ouvre sur une de vos
chaînes concurrentes expliqué qu en
vérité tous les comptes pouvait être
remis en question donc oui il a une
espèce de deux ans on voit bien la mère
ou la vie et nous nous au nom de ça on
se retrouve non pas avec une enquête
judiciaire normale avec un juge
d'instruction comme les autres partis
liés aux endroits bras avec une avec une
enquête préliminaire qui donne à
pouvoirs terribles procureur qui
lui-même est soudeur politique taupe
uni'sons que nous n'avons pas été
traités nord de manière normale et sa
maquette considérablement dans une
démocratie
merci eric coquerel émission est mal
malheureusement terminée on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour plus
d'actualité parlementaire merci à vous
d'avoir été avec nous bonne journée à
tous
[Musique]